earlier today during the campaign stop
in the Live Free or dive State of New
Hampshire former vice president Mike
Pence delivered a speech on conservatism
versus populism and the direction of the
Republican Party under former president
Trump's leadership take a look
so I came here to answer Anson College
to Simply say from my heart
the Republican voters face a choice
in the days to come
will we be the party of conservatism
or will we follow the siren song of
populism
unmoored to conservative principles
all right joining us now in studio uh
let's give a warm welcome former vice
president 2024 Republican candidate Mike
Pence is with us
so obviously the line a time for
choosing the the famous Reagan speech
right
um populism versus conservatism
um
you have said and we've discussed this
in great detail you and you even said it
in your speech today that you are very
proud of the all the accomplishments of
the Trump Pence Administration
okay do you so was that a conservative
running administration because I think
your policies were conservative but in
some cases a little more populist
especially when it came to getting out
of endless Wars Etc et cetera things
like that well look let me Begin by
saying it's great to see you thank you
and uh
I'm running for president because I
think this country's in a lot of trouble
I think we need new leadership in the
white house and we need to decide here
now that Joe Biden will never be
re-elected as president of the United
States
but to do that I think it's it's not
just going to be you know who is our
standard Bearer but what we stand for
and I want to agree with you very
strongly I think in the Trump Pence
Administration we governed as
conservatives we rebuild our military we
stood with our allies stood up to our
enemies I mean we cut taxes roll back
regulation Unleashed American Energy
created more than seven million good
paying jobs and achieved energy
Independence for the first time in 75
years and maybe most important at all we
appointed three conservatives to our
Supreme Court who gave America a new
beginning to the right to life
so we govern those conservatives
but I must tell you I I honestly believe
that there's a rising movement within
the Republican party that I think will
be a part of a debate in this primary
about whether or not we're going to stay
on that track of those Timeless
conservative principles of a strong
National Defense American leadership in
the world limited government fiscal
responsibility and the right to life or
whether we're going to follow the siren
song of populism unmoored conservative
principle and by that I mean there are
voices in our party
that not just my former running mate but
others that were on that stage with me a
few weeks ago that want to walk away
from American leadership on the world
stage literally want to want to abandon
our commitment as the Arsenal democracy
and the leader of the Free World on the
national debt look we have a we have a
national debt the size of our nation's
economy for the first time since World
War II Joe Biden's policy is insolvency
he won't even talk about the
entitlements it represents 70 percent of
our federal budget today and it
disappoints me that the former president
and others vying for the Republican
nomination I have the same position as
Joe Biden and on the right to life with
maybe one exception in the field
virtually every candidate for the
Republican nomination wants to
marginalize the right to life relegated
to the states only and I want people to
know that if I'm president of the United
States you're going to have a champion
for the right to life in the Oval Office
and we'll fight for protections for The
Unborn in every state house in America
and in Washington D.C let me get into a
little bit more of the specifics
in in many ways and I've said this to
you and I've said this to former
president trump it was the perfect
partnership but for the end
is that a fair I mean and I know it's a
big but I know there was a big
disagreement oh we had a great we had a
great working relationship right and I
got to see that I was there enough doing
enough interviews that I saw that yeah
you look you know president Trump was
not only my president he was my friend
some people think we were a little bit
different
right a little but the truth is truth is
personality wise you guys are pretty
different I I honestly think that uh in
2016 Donald Trump told America that he
would govern as a conservative he
obviously had a very diverse political
past he he'd taken liberal and
conservative views over the years there
was a lot of doubt about that at the
time well there was and some people I'm
humbled to say it but some people
thought that his selection of me as
someone that had been in the
conservative movement almost as long as
you have
gave evidence of the fact that he thanks
a lot almost as long but look I give I
give president Trump a lot of credit we
did govern as a conservative
administrator changed this time it was
there and what do you think changed well
is changing or what views do you believe
he would change on well I just I
there are voices in the movement far
beyond the Republican primary today
that look at War raging in Eastern
Europe Ukraine and suggests to the
American people that we have to choose
between being the leader of the Free
World and solving problems here at home
you know I made it very clear look any
anybody that says that we can't solve
the problems facing American families
here at home that we can't secure our
borders bring Law and Order to our
cities and be the leader of the Free
World
has a pretty small opinion of the
greatest nation on Earth we can do both
we're America let me ask you and I
believe that it's imperative on us to
produce leadership that that is willing
to step forward and say that I believe
there would be a big difference on the
issue of Ukraine for example if it was
the Trump Pence Administration you would
have insisted and demanded sure that
Europe pay their fair share and protect
their continent first they're not doing
that also just the way you beat the
caliphate and took out soleimani and
baghdadi and Associates you would if you
fought a war or committed to even some
of taxpayer money you would insist they
fight to win it you wouldn't have vetoed
28 migs that the way Joe Biden the
Russians would have never invaded
Ukraine I agree because we never had
that disastrous at all
we got to have leadership to stand
strong on the world stage and this is an
important debate it's just now beginning
Labor Day is behind us the Republican
primaries getting started but I want
people to know that I'm the most
qualified the most proven the most
tested conservative in this field and
I'm going to fight for a Republican
party that's grounded in those Timeless
conservative principles we'll see you
out at the Reagan Library uh if not
sooner thank you sir thank you sir thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else